Now before we finish,
I want to actually now showcase you, yet
another example of similar
coded photography.
Except this time,
we're going to talk about the concept
of a flutter shutter camera.
The flutter shutter camera,
basically now attempts to do
the same thing the coded camera did,
except that this time around rather
than change the aperture, it wants to
change something about the shutter.
In coded aperture,
we added obstructions to the aperture.
In flutter shutter, let's control
when the shutter opens and closes.
So, you know, again have the whole thing
and just figure out how to open and
close it in a specific manner.
Just to kind of look at this,
let's look at this series of examples.
A standard camera or traditional camera,
when it takes picture,
when the shutter is open,
you get one frame.
Right?
And these are ideas come from this
Raskar et al 2006 paper that's
represented at the end and
also we'll provide you the links
where to look at in detail.
I do encourage you to look at these
papers to kind of get a good sense of
the exact technical details.
I'm just summarizing them and giving you
the big overview of these concepts here.
So, of course,
when I open the shutter like this.
And if the car is moving, what I would
basically get is the car is moved and
if I actually have the shutter,
you'd actually get some sort of blur.
A motion blur in this instance, right?
Let's look at it again.
When I open the shutter,
the car is moving.
And of course,
depending how long the shutter is open,
I will get a blurry image like this.
Well, let's actually do
something interesting.
Let's actually change how
the shutter opens and
also control it when it closes.
So now basically what we'll do is
we'll open and close the shutter and
this is basically showing you this.
Now, if I know exactly how this opens
and closes, this is interesting.
Now, I do get a motion blur image.
But if you notice this one has
a very specific sharp lines.
Let's look at them next to each other,
this was when the shutter was open
the whole time and this was when
we kind of flutter shuttered it,
that is opened and
closed it at different rates.
Here everything is blurred.
In this one, you do see some blur.
But actually,there is a little
bit of a better signature.
So you, for example, see these lines
at different you know, there's no,
of course, detail here whatsoever.
But here, you actually see different
characteristic lines on this image.
This actually is much
more useful than this.
And if I actually know this code, then
I actually know a lot more about this
image too and that's the basic idea.
If I know the code on how and
when I open this,
I should be able to kind of use this
information to model the output that
I'm getting after all of this
is accumulated or integrated.
Here I know all of it, but since I have
no control over how the aspects of what
happened in the middle
everything is blurred.
So Raskar et al actually designed
this camera by actually just taking
an existing camera and putting some
sort of a additional controller that
would basically change the control
of how the shutter opens and
closes with a digital process here.
So they actually, could actually
figure out the exact code on how the,
the shutter would open.
So they created this new
camera to do this and
they did a lot of other
experiments with it.
Again, I recommend you to look
at the paper for more details.